Have you ever seen a photo of a planet made
entirely of living flesh?
Or an insect-human hybrid that can control
minds?
Or a thousand-foot-long sea serpent that emerges
in Iceland every year?
These images might look like they come from
some long-lost paranormal case file.
But this is actually the work of the brilliant
artist and worldbuilder Eduardo Valdés-Hevia,
who has spent the last several years bringing
to life a menagerie of nightmares so detailed
that I had to know more…
The Archivist: “So, what would you say inspires
your art?”
Valdés-Hevia: “I’m a really big fan of
the found-footage genre.
The type of horror that is not presented directly
as if you’re the subject, or you’re being
chased by this monster.
You’ve just found the diary of a person
that was chased by that monster.
And you are living that experience through
those documents…”
Brought to life through a combination of old
photographs and new elements, Valdés-Hevia’s
art merges history and the surreal, with images
that feel like they come directly from classified
historical documents.
The artist creates stand-alone images as well
as richly detailed series with dense, interconnected
lore.
So, for this entry into the archive, we’ll
investigate the monsters and madness of these
dark case files.
And you can support the artist on Patreon
and follow the projects using the links in
the description.
Now, prepare yourself for the terrors of Valdés-Hevia…
Valdés-Hevia’s longest project is the Megalamorpha
series, a fragmented anthology exploring humanity’s
many unfortunate encounters with mysterious,
insect-like lifeforms.
The Archivist: “What inspired the Megalamorpha
project?”
Valdés-Hevia: “I kind of modeled this story
after internet rabbit holes.
So, it’s a bunch of small stories.
In each of these stories there’s like one
piece of the puzzle — of that larger lore
— but only one.
You need to read a bunch of them to start
putting them together.”
One of the earliest fragments of the Megalamorpha
story comes from 1910 on the coast of Maine.
An unidentified carcass washes up on shore
— a strange shell that resembles a giant
insect.
Shortly after, the town’s fishermen who
discover it become paranoid that the abnormal
lifeform is cursed — and burn the remains
before scientists can examine them.
Another sighting comes in 1913, when the Australasian
Antarctic Expedition finds something strange
in the ice.
Recovered diary entries indicate that the
crew extracted the frozen lifeform from the
glacier and brought it back to camp.
Unfortunately, the specimen would be lost
later that winter, when crewman Sidney Jeffryes
came to believe the creature was trapped,
and wanted him to break it free.
In the end, he shattered the frozen block
with an axe, destroying the specimen within…
Valdés-Hevia: “The Megalamorpha, they can
kind of make themselves appear to the people
around them as whatever they interpret.
And it’s based on their previous beliefs.
What their background is.
They might think it’s some sort of deity…”
A recovered poster shows that a few years
later in the 1920s, the Turner Bros. Circus
began touring the USA with an unusual exhibit.
They claimed it was a species of ‘Amazonian
Mammoth Ant,’ although no such genus exists.
One of the two founders of the circus allegedly
became obsessed with the mysterious insect,
and began sleeping in the cage with it.
Eventually, he escaped with the ant, never
to be seen again...
A leaked report tells us that nearly a century
later in June of 1961, a group of Russian
navy personnel discovered something unsettling
in the Kara Sea.
Upon investigating a sunken merchant ship,
a diver came upon the nest of some sort of
creature.
Analysis of the eggs determined they belonged
to a species previously unknown to science.
But while the diver’s camera was recovered,
the diver was not.
The rest of the crew deemed the waters unsafe
to investigate further, and what eventually
became of the site remains a mystery.
Researcher Nigel Buckley tracked down the
details for most of the Megalamorpha sightings
, making it his life’s work to collect the
scattered reports on the creatures before
passing away in 1986.
Fragments of notes and illustrations indicate
Buckley believed the lifeforms were related
to insects.
Despite the Megalamorpha’s extreme variability
in appearance, Buckley theorized they were
a single species that went through radical
metamorphosis over their life cycle.
While Buckley could not prove the existence
of these nightmares, the sightings continued
after his death.
But we’ll come back to the Megalamorpha…
Another brilliant horror series is The Façade
— a paranoia-inducing work that comes from
a collaboration between Valdés-Hevia and
fellow artist Luke Baker.
Valdés-Hevia: “I love Luke’s art, so
we were chatting one day and I was like: we
should collab on something.
We converged on the topic of doppelgangers.”
The story begins in 1865.
A photographer reveals his latest invention
to the French Emperor’s court: the Turning
portrait.
Yet the portrait of one Baron Renard comes
out… wrong.
The camera is deemed defective.
Unbeknownst to the court, the real problem
is that the individual in the photograph isn’t
actually Renard.
The next sighting of this lifeform — known
as the Façade — comes in 1896, when during
the X-ray craze, people buy machines to show
to party guests.
In one such event in Hamburg, financier Franz
Mansfeld has this plate taken, revealing him
to be the Façade.
He keeps the print a secret until vanishing
years later.
Decades pass without sightings until 1960,
when a 6-year-old from Chicago is admitted
to the Lurie Children’s Hospital.
In a crayon drawing, she claims there is a
monster pretending to be her mother.
Her records show another breakdown at age
23, thought to be at the time when the Façade
chose a new victim.
Valdés-Hevia: “It changes identities.
Every time it’s found out, it’ll go out,
kill someone else, and become them.”
The last sighting comes in 1977, when a bystander
reports to the Chicago PD that he saw a man
with a shifting face swallow someone whole.
His story wasn’t believed, although a single
police sketch was made of the suspect.
The report was not investigated, and the Façade’s
current location remains unknown…
Many of Valdés-Hevia’s most striking pieces
don’t belong to a series, but are stand
alone works.
Like this photograph of a group of people
watching the emergence of the ‘Niddhogg.’
“The whole idea is this huge creature, the
Niddhogg, every year explodes from the ground.
But I want to set it into a world where it’s
a completely normal thing and everybody is
used to it.”
The name Niddhogg comes from Norse mythology,
and belongs to a dragon that gnaws at a root
of the world tree.
Yet the people in these images don’t revere
the Nigghogg as something mythic, but rather
a spectacle to be gawked at — which feels
strangely realistic.
Taking hoaxes and pieces of folklore and turning
them into something more realistic is a motif
that appears frequently throughout Valdés-Hevia’s
art.
For example, “Jenny Hanivers” are hoaxes
created by taking the dried carcass of a ray
and fashioning it into a fanciful creature
to sell to tourists.
Yet one piece by Valdés-Hevia imagines a
deep-sea submarine capturing a ‘live specimen’
on camera — revealing an uncanny and human-like
lifeform staring back from the dark abyss.
It’s impressive how the art turns a rather
ridiculous piece of folklore into something
actually fear-provoking.
And Valdés-Hevia isn’t afraid to embrace
absurdity and horror at the same time.
One of my favorite pieces shows a trail camera
catching something strange on the 25th of
December, 2020.
The following Christmas, the owner of the
camera hears a horrible cracking sound like
breaking bones coming from their fireplace.
Figuring migratory birds had made a nest inside,
they take a picture up the chimney…
Valdés-Hevia: “The creepy and the funny
is something really easy to mix together.
I like doing both.”
One of the best combinations of creepy and
funny comes from the crab person images — a
project in which volunteer test subjects undergo
a procedure intended to evolve their human
body plans into something more advanced…
with unexpected results.
Valdés-Hevia: “A mad scientist tried to
speed up evolution just to see what mankind
would evolve into.
And — oh no — it evolved into crabs.”
This series is a play on carcinization — or
the tendency of crustaceans to evolve into
crabs, an amusing natural phenomenon I’ve
discussed before on the channel.
So, perhaps the ultimate human would also
have a defensive ribcage shell and a keratinous
claw.
Of course, some of Valdés-Hevia’s work
is more overtly terrifying.
Returning to the fragmented Megalamorpha series,
the next glimpse of the giant insects’ influence
comes in Norway in 1953.
Here, an isolated church becomes a strange
cult, worshiping a mysterious being.
Journalist Erling Jørgensen is allowed to
visit the community and take pictures, although
he is not permitted to enter the church during
sermon hours.
According to Erling’s notes, however, on
the day of his departure, he is overtaken
by curiosity.
Sneaking into the church, he sees an immense,
moth-like creature appear on the wall.
The congregation is silent as the monstrous
insect pulsates— seemingly under its control.
Valdés-Hevia: “In my Megalamorpha series,
it’s all about these giant insects manipulating
people and kind of brainwashing them.
This one that specializes in releasing pheromones
with this huge organ could brainwash a whole
group of people.”
After the sermon ends, a fire destroys the
church and the insect that day.
It is only years later — upon Erling’s
death — that it is revealed that he is the
one who lit the match…
But the story of the Megalamorpha doesn’t
end there.
More recent discoveries in fact suggest that
the creatures may have been appearing for
centuries.
In 1982, a local news channel in Sicily discovers
something bizzare.
On the wall of a Roman ruin, a mosaic depicts
what looks like an enormous wasp eating an
antelope.
The piece stands out from the other realistic
scenes and does not seem to match any known
Roman myths.
In a medieval codex from 15th century Spain,
the Megalamorpha seem to appear again.
While traveling in a boat, a nobleman’s
son discovers an unusual cocoon in the sea,
which soon begins to alter his mind.
When an insect hatches from the cocoon, the
nobleman’s son believes the creature to
be holy, and has numerous statues made in
its honor — all of which have bug-like features.
But other pieces indicate that human interactions
with the Megalamorpha go back much further.
Neolithic paintings in a cave found near Tírig,
Spain depict what appears to be people fighting
a large six-legged insect.
In the next image, however, people kneel before
a similar figure in a more solemn pose.
They appear to be making offerings to it.
The following part seems to depict the next
stage in the insect’s lifecycle, but it
has been purposefully chiseled off — leaving
few recognizable traces.
The final scene shows more people kneeling
and laying down their weapons below beings
that show elements of both humans and the
previous six-limbed creatures — an image
that is perhaps the most unsettling of all.
Near the paintings is a human skull with unknown
malformations.
Taken as a whole, it seems the Megalamorpha’s
lifecycle eventually involves merging with
human hosts.
But we’ll come back to that story…
Across Valdés-Hevia’s gallery of terrors,
another ingeniously bizarre concept is Xipe-Totec
— a planet seemingly made of living flesh
that passes close to Earth.
There’s something cosmically terrifying
and strangely amusing about this visual — with
veins crisscrossing the planet like rivers,
and spots that resemble eyes where craters
should be.
The Archivist: So, what can you tell us about
the planet made of living flesh?
Valdés-Hevia: It does have a little bit of,
you know, speculative biology stuff.
As accurate as you can get about, you know,
meat planets.
It looks red and meaty, and that is because
it uses a pigment, kind of like chlorophyl,
to absorb energy from stars.
And to move around, it needs to expel some
matter…
kind of like, fart around the universe in
a way.
In the story that accompanies these images,
after passing close to Earth, the Xipe-Totec
leaves behind fragments torn from its surface
due to earth’s gravitational pull.
Authorities warn people not to approach the
debris — as it still seems to pulse with
life, which doesn’t bode well.
And after the planet leaves the solar system,
the probe Voyager 2 takes a space photo of
what appears to be another member of the Xipe-Totecs
species that is now just a skeleton.
Valdés-Hevia: “So the bone version of the
meat planet that we see was one of these planets
that didn’t make it.
It was very unlucky, and it didn’t find
a new star system, and kept roaming around
until it was just a husk...”
One of Valdés-Hevia’s longer series is
The Lycanthrope Project — an exploration
of an alternate history with werewolves made
in collaboration with the talented horror
artist David Romero.
The mixed media series brilliantly reimagines
the werewolf mythos, reframing the monsters’
relationship to society in unexpected ways.
The Archivist: “So, what was the vision
behind The Lycanthrope Project?”
Valdés-Hevia: “One of the driving concepts
we had behind this was putting the Werewolf
where the vampire usually is.
So, the vampire usually works as this aristocratic
killer.
It’s the personification of the nobleman
leeching off the regular people.
And removing the vampire from there and putting
a werewolf — which is usually this bestial
thing.
It’s not usually a creature that’s in
control.”
One of the earliest depictions of werewolves
in the story of The Lycanthrope Project comes
from a Roman mosaic, which depicts a party
of hunters killing a lycanthrope.
The curse of the wolf is passed on through
bloodlines.
And although in this image the werewolves
are hunted, powers soon shift as individuals
with the curse rise through the ranks of nobility.
The next image depiction comes from a Medieval
triptych, commissioned in the twelfth century
by a secret society of knights called the
Order of the New Moon.
This group of werewolves, which features heavily
in The Lycanthrope Project, believe themselves
to be a chosen, holy people — destined to
rule over the masses.
Inching closer to the present, an old photograph
shows how in some insular Nordic communities,
old customs of worshiping Lycanthropes are
still maintained.
In ancient times, these groups practiced initiation
rites that often including wearing masks shaped
like wolf heads — showing how the influence
of werewolves has spread across the globe.
In time, the ranks of the secretive Order
of the New Moon open to a select few.
At the dawn of the 20th century, powerful
figures begin intermarrying into the family
— lured by the promise of joining the Lycan
Bloodline.
Today, the higher ranks of the enigmatic Order
are said to be formed by the rich and powerful
from across the world.
The full extent of their reach, however, is
left a mystery.
Like many of Valdés-Hevia’s projects, the
narrative is intentionally open ended, encouraging
the viewer to fill in the gaps...
And to conclude our look into the mind of
Valdés-Hevia, we’ll return one final time
to the terrors of the Megalamorpha project.
Some of the most illuminating fragments of
the narrative are the last surviving photographs
from the secretive De La Cruz family — which
at last offer us a look at a Megalamorpha-human
hybrid.
According to Adrián De La Cruz — a disowned
relative who smuggled the photographs out
of the family estate — the monster in this
image was known to the family as “Tío Alfredo.”
Adrián claims the creature has always been
there since the time of his great-grandfathers,
having convinced their minds it was part of
the family.
The Archivist: “So, how did you approach
designing the Megalamorpha-human hybrid?”
Valdés-Hevia: “It took me a long time to
kind of figure out how to mix those bug and
human elements.
It’s carrying the bones outside — the
human part of it is kind of out in the exoskeleton.”
According to the account of Adrián De La
Cruz, he planned to bring an end to the creature
by drinking a bottle of cyanide and letting
it feed upon him.
It is unclear if he was successful…
In any case, the tale of the Megalamorpha
continues into the modern era.
In 2004, a company charting the sea floor
off the coast of Hawaii discovers an abandoned
remotely operated vehicle.
The vehicle was lost during the survey of
a sunken ship, with its umbilical cord cut
off.
And on the vehicle’s camera is a photo of
a familiar insect-like creature which seems
to have been the cause of the vehicle’s
disappearance — and perhaps the wreck of
the ship itself.
The final glimpse of the Megalamorpha comes
in the form of trail cam pictures from 2006
recovered from a now defunct online hunting
forum.
As for what happened to the Megalamorpha from
here, however, is anyone’s guess.
For who can say what lurks in the dark corners
of the world?
This brief glimpse into the striking and surreal
creations of Eduardo Valdés-Hevia leaves
many questions still unanswered.
But, according to the artist himself, a mystery
is most engaging when there’s a little ambiguity.
Valdés-Hevia: “I’m not one for giving
out the whole lore to everybody because I
think that ruins a little bit of the fun.
It’s that found horror thing where it makes
you dig for more.
You are kind of cursing yourself with knowledge,
but you need to know more.”
If you’d like to discover more of this mysterious
art for yourself, there are links in the description.
A tremendous thank you to Eduardo Valdés-Hevia
for sharing insights into his many projects.
Once again, you can support him on Patreon
and follow him on social media using the links
down below.
And as always, thanks for watching.
If you enjoyed this entry, please lend your
support by liking, subscribing, and hitting
the notification icon to stay up to date on
all things Curious.
See you in the next video.